and vice president kamala harris talking  climate resiliency during her stop at  lake mead today she along with  representatives dina titus stephen  horsford and susie lee met with  officials from the bureau of reclamation  now the big focus the western  drought the infrastructure the  bipartisan infra infrastructure deal  combined with the build back better  agenda is about what we need to do to  invest in things like water recycling  and reuse  what we can do in terms of water  desalination  what we can do in terms of  implementation of drought contingency  plans  she says 90 percent of western states  are facing some level of drought we  should also mention here local media was  not allowed to attend or ask questions  brian